centrifuge tubes are used for separating  Solutions we choose screwtop centrifuge  tubes to secure the sample and if we  want to be able to write on top of it  use a plug top screw cap to secure the  sample they are designed with a conical  bottom to easily extract the solution  and to fit into the machine the three  kinds are plug flat and flip top plug  can write on it but they have a better  seal flat you can write on them and flip  top you can also write on them they just  have the worst seal out of the three  centrifuge tubes can handle 16 000 G's  Max Force Under certified dnase rnas  free to prevent sample contamination  they also have printed graduation marks  and a large writing patch for easy  identification of the sample